Okay. What's your background, your
question, Sam?
>> I am a Palestinian Orthodox. I emailed I
messaged you on Facebook last night.
>> Did you?
>> Yeah. Yeah, I sent you the AP article. I
told you that the none is 100% correct
on everything.
>> Oh, you did? That's right. Let me see.
Yeah, because I have four pages. One
started by others. I have a Ben Malik
account, Sam Shimon account, and Billy
Thomaselli.
>> I
Yeah,
>> that's my real name. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Okay. So, brother, that's fine. I'm not
going to mention your real name. So, do
you have any questions, comments?
>> Um,
no. I just want to say that like
everything the lady said is just like
crazy on on point. Like I really
appreciate you guys touching on this
because that's our reality, you know?
That's like
>> Tell them your background again. So, you
know, tell them what your background is.
>> Palestinian Palestinian Orthodox from
Bethlehem. So,
>> okay, hear this guys. Palestinian
Orthodox.
Orthodox from Palestine.
So this lady that appeared, this
Orthodox nun on Tucker Carlson's
show,
can you tell us whether she was 100%
spoton or she's lying? And how would you
know? Have you been exposed to that?
>> I lived there the first 17 years of my
life. um um from the city called Bay
Jala. She mentioned the tunnel that she
mentioned is goes through right under
our house. Matter of fact, when they use
DMT to open it, the cracks from our
house just like our wall cracked. So
that that's like right under my house.
The people she mentioned, I know them.
The doctor she mentioned, we know him.
She mentioned my high school. She
mentioned my church. Um nuns like her
literally raised us from kindergarten
until high school. You know, I went to
the Lutheran school. she she mentioned
and every everything is correct like you
know like I don't understand why AP and
his likes I used to like him like are
attacking her but I people like her
literally raised us and it's just a sad
to see that no one is standing with us.
It's it's a shame.
>> So people like her raised you and you
can testify that these Palestinian
Christians are godly people who love the
Lord, right?
>> Oh yeah. Oh. Oh yeah. We're like we're
we're all like fine. We there's a lot of
Orthodox of us, some Catholics, some
Lutherans. We're all like there's no
issues between us. I mean, even with
>> Say again.
>> I mean,
>> Lutheran, Orthodox, Catholics, no issues
among you, right?
>> Yeah. I mean, I went my entire life to a
Lutheran school, you know, and I'm I'm a
Greek Orthodox and I went to a Lutheran
school. There's absolutely no issue with
that. Um, half of my classmates, if not
most of them were Muslim that used to
sit in the morning prayer, our heavenly
father with us. They used to stand up
for the prayer. They respected that. We
have no issues with the Muslim. Now,
obviously, because we're minority,
whenever you have to walk on the
sidewalk because if you there's a fight,
nobody got your back. This is normal for
any minority. But the fact that they say
were persecuted, crap. Crap. It's not.
And I don't even like the other side,
you know, like I'm just telling you the
truth.
>> Yeah. And you were raised in Palestine.
Obviously, you hate Islam. You think
Muhammad is a false prophet, but you're
going to have to speak the truth. Not
all the Muslims there are terrorists or
terrorized.
>> My my best friend is absolutely Muslim,
devout Muslim. one of my closest friends
and uh just because I have an issue with
their religion, that doesn't mean I'm
gonna have issue with the people I grew
up with and I love. You know what I
mean? That's like their I try to bring
them to the truth. I try to use your
arguments and everything that I can to
open their eyes, but I'm not going to
just sit there and batch these people
that I grew up with, you know? I mean,
sure, there's a lot of Hamas bad guys,
but there's also a lot of Hamas good
guys. Like, like I'm a Christian. I have
no dog in this fight,
>> you know.
>> And remember, though, be careful because
there Oh, Hamas good guys. No, brethren,
understand what he's saying. Because I
trying to put myself in his shoes. Some
people join kamas because they're
convinced Israel. Israelis are the
occupiers. Kamas is a response to them.
Let me repeat. Understand where they're
coming from. So you don't demonize this
guy too and say he's a demon.
>> I can tell you so many stories, Sam. Um
growing up in the second father, they we
would see our neighbors house. They
would come give them 15 minutes to get
out of there and they would just up for
no reason like
>> but let me explain your comment. I know
brother I want to explain because he's
going to now demonize you. What he means
is
some people join kamas because they're
convinced the Israelis stole their land
and that they are the oppressors.
They are the murderers and you need to
stand up against them. One man's saint
is another man's heretic. Understand
what he's telling you? If you're
convinced the Jews stole your land,
that's what you're convinced. Then
obviously you're going to join a
resistance group because you think you
owe it to your people who are suffering
or being buildings up and you owe it to
your land to fight against these evil
occupiers. That's the mindset. Whether
they're right or wrong, this is what
they believe. This is what they're
taught. This is what they see. We see
since 1948.
They have occupied our land. They came
in, drove us out from our homes, took
over our land, and they have control
over our water and electricity, and they
have caged us in like rats in a cage. Of
course, they're the ones who are evil.
We need to fight them. That doesn't mean
they're right. That doesn't mean they're
wrong. It's perspective. And as a
Palestinian, a Palestinian, he doesn't
see, oh, the Jews, they just want to
coexist. They want a piece of the land
and live co pe pe pe pe pe pe pe pe pe
pe pe pe pe pe pe pe pe pe pe pe
peacefully with us. No, they took over
the homes of even Palestinian
Christians. They've got us like birds in
a cage. They control our water supply,
electricity. They're churches. They're
down even Palestinian Christians. Of
course, they're the ones who are evil
and were the victims. See, it's
perspective.
>> Yeah. Um, our land, my grandpa's land
was confiscated. I remember my dad
telling me he used to go up with his
grandpa and then just farm it. And I can
see it from our house and now they
opened an entire city and they put um
settlements in it and I I can pass by it
every day and it's just sad that I can't
access it and some Eastern European kids
live in it. Um,
>> who's living in your lands of your
ancestors? I mean I mean the Eastern
European they bring I mean Israel has a
habit of bringing a lot of people from
Europe. They pay their monthly salaries.
They pay them just to live there. Which
is why whenever October 7th happened um
everybody in Israel ran to the airports
because everybody wanted to leave. Um
now this time when Iran started Israel
what they did um Netanyahu sent all the
planes out. He doesn't want the Jews to
leave. Well, because if you're the owner
of the land, you will die in your land.
These people come from Europe. You know,
whenever a a drops, they run to the
airport while we sit there and look at
them and laugh, you know, like we're
used to this. This is our land. They can
they run straight to the airport. And it
sucks that this is my grandpa's land and
I can't access it. But then there's some
blonde blue-eyed kid sitting there with
his parents in it.
>> I'm a Christian, you know. I don't have
a dog in this fight. in a land and in a
house that was owned by your
grandparents, your ancestors. That were
there, right?
>> Yes, sir. Yes, sir. And we we're in an
area C. I'm sure you the none mentioned
ABC. C is basically West Bank controlled
by Israel. So, this the
>> what's controlled by Israel again. Say
again.
>> We are in an area classified C. Uh
there's like ABC is full with the
Palestinian. C is like a mixed area.
It's under it's with the West Bank, but
um whoever police it is the Israeli
military. So they would they would walk
in into like whenever they want they
would just go bust in your house, ruin
your parents' room, look for nothing,
and just scare you and walk out. Like
it's insane. It's a it's like this
happens all the time. Uh whatever the
said is 100% right. I I when we were um
back in middle school, one of our high
school kids, I don't know him
personally, he actually uh did a and
because they his brother that was back
then and I didn't know him, I heard the
stories, but then they just blew his
house. So, if you want to understand why
kids who went to Christian school would
end up doing stuff that Hamas does is
not out of thin air. They have their
parents, their siblings, and everything.
So for us, we kind of understand, we
don't agree with it, but we understand
why these people do what they
>> Yeah, that's what I'm trying to tell
people, brother Sam, to understand what
you're saying and their perspective,
whether right or wrong, but they don't
want to. They don't want to hear it. So,
it is what it is. But thank God,
brother, there are now a lot of voices,
a lot of voices that are speaking out
for the Palestinians and are not
justifying this terrorist Netanyahu
because he's a terrorist. I think he's
scum. I have no respect for him.
No. So there are a lot. So don't don't
think it's an isolated voices. There's a
lot more voices than you think. Even
conservatives, Christians, Tucker
Carlson, you see what they're doing to
Candace Owen. They're demonizing her.
>> That's crazy. Yeah.
>> You're making her look like a demon. I
mean, I've heard David Wood and even
apostate prophet demonize her. So it's
like you can't touch Israel. It's the
sacred cow. Because if you do, Candace
Owen demonized. Tucker Carlson
demonized. Everyone who speaks out is
being demonized. But it doesn't work. We
don't fall for it. We don't care what
people think. Truth is truth. But I
thank God you came up as the final
person to speak because I wanted to hear
your voice as a Palestinian Orthodox
Christian. He's part of the Greek
Orthodox Church. And he confirms
absolutely 100% the nun is spot on.
100%.
>> Yeah. Are there any Palestinian
Christians who live there that would go
against what she said that you know of?
>> No, I'm actually planning on going back
there next year. Uh but no, man.
Everything I mean, listen, I I call my
cousins every day. I talk to them. It's
unfortunate. They live in the West Bank.
There's no jobs. The people that can go
work in Israel are not allowed to go in
Israel anymore. Everybody's like
struggling. But I mean, nobody
disagreed. This is our reality. I mean,
I can literally put 15 people on the
phone with you right now when we get off
in private and you can speak to the
people that live back home. This is our
reality. And just like I literally lost
so respect for AP and I don't I don't
want to keep bashing the guy, but the
fact that people like her who literally
raised us
>> um people like this guy have no idea
that the family that has the keys for
the holy supplr are Muslim for the last
a thousand years. They come every
morning, they open our church and they
lock it at night. It's the Muslim family
who The family that
>> opens with the holy suppla for you. Say
it again. For how many years?
>> Limbs. Muslim family generation after
another. They have the keys of our
church. They open it for us in the
morning and they and they lock it at
night. I mean even us the Christians,
Armenian, Catholic, cops, even among
each other. We we are fighting over the
church and inside. And then our key
issues with a Muslim. I mean listen, I
no I don't like Islam and I don't like
like Judaism. Like I have no dou in this
fight. AJ is a Muslim.
>> We have to be fair. We have to be fair.
>> You know, like you walk into the streets
of Bethlehem, it's 99% Muslims and
absolutely no no problem. You know, like
it's a beautiful place to be. All the
tourists go to the holy nativity church
where which we used to pray every Sunday
there. Um and you know, we we have a
saying in our Christian community, eat
with the Jew and sleep at the Muslim's
house. And um I don't know if you can
understand that. Eat with the Jew and
sleep at the Muslim's house because from
our experience with them, the Muslim
will never when you're sleeping, but the
Jewish will.
>> That's their that's a saying among them.
He's saying because they don't trust.
>> That's a saying among us. Yes. So
>> they don't because remember his
perspective, guys. He's this is what
they've experienced. This is how they
feel. They have no trust. how you feel
about Muslims is how the Palestinians
feel about Israel because they feel this
is what Israel's done to them whether
right or wrong. Right.
>> And also Sam, I want to leave you with
one thing. I know you spoke about uh
people seeing stuff when they're um
passing away. Uh 2021, I live here in
California. I took my grandpa to the
airport to go visit back home for the
summer. And he told me, "Grandson, I'm
going to die there. I'm not coming
back." And I'm like, "What are you
talking about? I'm going to pick you up
in like two months." He's like, "No, I'm
I'm going to go get buried next to your
grandma." I'm like, "Okay, whatever you
say." However, he went there. He he fall
sick
>> and um at the same time um something
happened. It was 11:00 p.m. here and he
was in his last days in the hospital. He
was still conscious and everything. And
it was 11:00 p.m. here. We went to sleep
and um
at uh at about 12:00 p.m. my mom had a
dream from my grandma who passed away 20
something years and my grandma told my
mom that um and I came and we took him
and like peacefully and we woke up 30
seconds later to a minute later we get
the phone call from back home
>> that my grandpa left peacefully and uh
he was calling his mom's name while he
was surrendering his soul. So everything
you said earlier, I can testify
firsthand in it.
>> Did you hear it, guys? His grandfather
said, "I'm not coming back. I'm going to
go to be with your grandmother." The day
he died, his mother saw her mother.
Tell her, "We've taken him. He's at
peace." They wake up. They got a call.
Hey, your father, his grandfather passed
away. And he was crying out for his
mother.
>> Confirmation.
>> Minutes. Yeah, that was minutes after
like whenever my mom had the dream and
woke up. It was like what 1:00 a.m. Like
a few minutes later, we get the call
from my uncles who are by his bedsides.
>> I mean that's like that's not a
coincidence. No way.
>> Well, no. I told you guys remember I
told you about Berean visions and
visions. So, did you catch it? So, his
grandfather So, it's your mother's
father, right?
>> Uh, no, actually my father's father.
>> Okay. Father. So, the grandmother that
came to your mother was your father's
mother.
>> Yes. Yeah. Her mother-in-law. Yes.
>> Okay. So, watch this. Let's repeat it
again. Grandfather tells him father's
father, "You're not going to see me. I'm
going to go to die and I'm going to join
your grandmother." No, no, no, no. The
day he dies within minutes, his mother
sees her mother-in-law, which was the
wife of his grandfather,
saying, "We've come and we've taken him.
He's at peace."
wakes up few minutes later, phone call.
Oh yes, your father-in-law, his
grandfather, father's father died. And
he was crying out to his mother. So he
was seeing his mother. God had opened
the veil. Miraculous confirmation. Death
is not the end. Jesus is alive and his
grandfather is with his grandmother with
Jesus in heaven. There you go, brother.
>> 100%. 100%.
>> Thank you, man. Now, Sam, you know what
you're going to do right now? People
hear about this interview now. They're
going to demonize you and me. Look,
yeah, Sam brought in the P. So pray for
me, brother. We finished the race and we
glorify Christ and not care what people
say.
>> I will. And hopefully when you're in
California, I can take you to visit our
church. I go to Father Josiah's church.
Beautiful church.
>> To watch information about you, brother.
I'll probably be up there. I'll be up
there at the end of August around your
area.
>> Yeah, reach me. You have me on Facebook.
I would love to sit down and meet with
you.
>> Yes. And pray that I'm at least as
skinny and handsome as you. I got to
drop 15 pounds to fit in my clothes.
>> Me, too. I'm getting married in two
months and I need to lose 15. So, we're
engaged.
>> Also, I'm I'm a really I'm a really good
cook. So, if we meet, you're not going
to lose any pounds.
>> I'm gonna have to see you after a year
then when I lose 40 pounds. Oh, love
you, brother.
>> Thank you, Sam. Thank you so much, bro.
Have a good day. Bye.